propose maintenant un zoom sur cette
première journée de campagne de second
tour et même macron qui ne fait pas la
même erreur qu'il ya cinq ans quand il y
avait eu 24 heures 48 heures
d'hésitation de se lancer pour de bon
manu emmanuel macron était sur le
terrain dès aujourd'hui dès ce matin
dans le nord canton marine le pen a
choisi ses lionnes pour son premier
déplacement cécile sexo
à peine qualifié emmanuel macron donne
le ton la campagne du deuxième tour ne
ressemblera pas à celle du premier cette
fois il sera sur le terrain
aujourd'hui à denain dans le nord sur
les terres de marine le pen le président
candidat sera demain dans l'est de la
france
ces équipes réunies ce matin au qg
confirme cette fois il compte bien
occuper le terrain il pourrait faire un
déplacement par jour dont plusieurs
meetings le premier aura lieu ce samedi
à marseille a échappé que le président a
eu forcément une campagne resserrée mais
là il est déjà sur le terrain
aujourd'hui va l'être dans les tout
prochains jours et nous aussi et le mot
d'ordre cette fois défendre le programme
il suffit pas aujourd'hui d'aller
montrer que le programme de luc deleu
marine le pen et irréalité dangereux il
faut aussi démontré que le programme que
nous développons est un programme de
cohésion est un problème de conquête et
c'est cela qu'on va s'attacher à faire
demain rien n'est joué avant le deuxième
tour il faut être mobilisés programme
contre programme c'est ce que nous
faisons de son côté marine le pen
applaudit ce matin par sa garde
rapprochée compte bien elle aussi occupé
l'espace face à l'omniprésence annoncée
du président candidat elle a déjà changé
ses plans et fera trois déplacements
quinze jours au lieu de deux je repars
dès cet après-midi sur le terrain
j'y serai bien entendu tout au long de
ce second tour même si je considère
qu'il est important également de faire d
organiser des des conférences de presse
dans l'objectif d'expliquer précisément
aux français quelle est notre projet la
candidate tiendra également un meeting à
avignon ce jeudi elle retrouvera
emmanuel macron pour le débat d'entre
deux tours mercredi 20 avril
et pour ce débat politique j'accueille
xavier iacovelli bonsoir vous êtes
sénateur et les oem des hauts-de-seine
jean paul garraud bonsoir député
européen rassemblement national vous
êtes magistrat futur ministre la justice
si marine le pen est élue en tout cas
c'est ce que
disait encore jordan dare della ce matin
valérie boyer bonsoir vous êtes
sénatrice l ère des bouches du rhône
avec non duplex également thomas porte
les vice présidents du parlement de
l'union populaire soutien de jean luc
mélenchon bonsoy avoue matthieu
croissandeau évidemment toujours à mes
côtés et s commence avec vous mathieu
puisque vous allez dans ce débat a
analysé les forces et les faiblesses des
deux finalistes on commence par emmanuel
macron basse et forcé tiennent d'abord
dans son résultat 10 et 1 malgré une
mauvaise campagne et sans doute
peut-être aussi un peu à cause de cette
mauvaise campagne le président sortant a
fait peur un peu ses partisans et
entraîné un surcroît de mobilisation est
donc son score d'hier est en nette
progression par rapport à 2010 est en
pourcentage et en voix et sa première
place devrait lui conférer quand même
une forme de dynamique on n'a pas vu
depuis 1995 un candidat arrivé en tête
ne pas être élu président 95 c'était
jospin aux soldats étaient par exemple
voilà côté fort sill son tempérament
personnel
ils l'aiment l'adversité des campagnes
il l'a prouvé en 2017 il aime aller au
contact ils aiment débattre il est
plutôt pas mauvais il est plutôt bon
c'est tout ce qu'on a pas vu faire en
fait avant ce premier tour voilà est-ce
qu'il as qu'il a repris aujourd'hui il
al'expérience ensuite parce qu'il est
président sortant ce qui lui confère une
forme d'autorité une forme de
présomption de compétence je veux dire
même si les gens sont pas forcément
d'accord ils disent bon ben il doit
savoir faire il a des troupes militantes
qui ont maigri mais il a encore des
troupes militantes il a des lieutenants
sur le papier il sent peu le plus à même
de pouvoir composer une équipe
gouvernementale que son adversaire où on
se pose toujours la question il a un
programme et puis il faut dire que le
front républicain qu'on disait mort et
enterré à fonctionner hier en tout cas
par la voix de deux de ses représentants
des drm entendu plusieurs candidats dire
qu'ils voteront personnellement pour
emmanuel macron et d'autres qui ne l'ont
pas dit dire qu'il ne fallait pas une
voix à marine le pen et ses faiblesses
c'est exactement le revers de la
médaille de toutes ses forces son score
est fort mais il est insuffisant et ses
réserves de voix sont humains ce qu'en
2017 est beaucoup plus compliquée à
aller chercher notamment auprès des
électeurs de jean dit que mais la
chambre de jean luc mélenchon pardon
pour qui emmanuel macron c'était le
diable depuis cinq ans
son tempérament je le disais et ça peut
lui il aimait le contact qu'il est
plutôt plutôt pas mauvais là dedans en
revanche son tempérament peut passer
aussi parfois pour de l'arrogance la
suffisance dans cette campagne l'a perdu
on verra si le récupère mais le combat
de la proximité le coin de la proximité
c'est plutôt son adversaire marine le
pen qu'il a gagné son expérience je
disais c'est un c'est un atout mais
c'est aussi son bilan et chaque mesure
qu'il va proposer va naturellement
déboucher sur une question qui sera
pourquoi ne l'avez vous pas fait avant
et puis on dit que les l'elysée isole et
ça c'est aussi quelque chose dont il
semble avoir souffert dans cette pré
campagne dans cette campagne de premier
tour en fin de son programme gilles un
programme c'est vrai mais les français
ont surtout retenu qu'une addition de
mesures davantage qu'un projet ou une
vision et un slogan nous tous mais
voilà qui n'est pas encore pas très bien
ce que ça dessine en 2017 on voyait bien
d'une certaine façon qui voulait
débloquer la france à sa façon
aujourd'hui on voit c'est plutôt stop ou
encore et puis surtout pire dans le
programme les français ont surtout
retenu une mesure qui est la fameuse en
retraite à 65 ans qui est vêtus pour
beaucoup d'entre eux comme une mesure
punitive et en particulier dans lectorat
qui convoitent c'est à dire celui de
jean-luc mélenchon donc il va devoir
élargir sans dénaturer son projet sans
passer non plus pour un opportuniste qui
au dernier moment sortir et il mesure de
son chapeau ou ou la volonté de parc
créé par exemple un des très grands
partis commun dans l'entre-deux tours
bref tout ça s'annonce quand même plus
compliqué qu'il n'y paraît pour cette
première place un petit peu en forme de
trompe l'oeil pour emmanuel macron
xavier iacovelli élargir le projet sans
le dénaturer est ce que c'est ça le défi
de votre candidat pour les 13 prochains
jours moi ce que je note déjà c'est que
vous l'avez indiqué emmanuel macron
c'est le seul président le seul candidat
président qui a élargi son socle depuis
le début du quinquennat la majorité
s'est élargi par rapport à celles qui
étaient présentes qui a été élu en 2010
est moi j'en suis la preuve je suis
arrivé en encours de quinquennat mais ça
se voit aussi dans les résultats puisque
vous l'avez dit quatre points quatre à
cinq points de plus par rapport au score
de 2017 en pourcentage et en électeurs
donc on voit bien qu'il ya un
élargissement et une prise de conscience
aussi des français n'ont pas un
satisfecit mais en tout cas un
accompagnement sur le projet et le bilan
du président de la république donc moi
sur la question du projet élargir son
projet sans la nature l'a dit il a dit
il prend en compte aussi le résultat du
premier tour il ya une fois une forte
demande notamment sur la question de
l'écologie il a dit qu'il était prêt à
élargir son programme sur la question
écologique et c'est vrai qu' aujourd'hui
lorsqu'on compare les deux programme des
ceux qui sont qualifiés pour le second
tour aujourd'hui nous avons nous à la
fois un bilan sur l'écologie mais aussi
des propositions qui vont a été
effectivement élargie avec d'autres
propositions qui vont venir dans les
jours qui viennent face a effectivement
une candidate qui elle prône la sortie
du green deal ou la rupture avec les
accords de paris donc on voit bien que
c'est aussi projet contre projet qui qui
va être important pour ce second tour
jean-paul garraud quel est le point
faible des macros d'abord je dirais que
emmanuel macron commencera campagne donc
hélas il va s'impliquer pour 12 jours de
campagne c'est le moins que l'on puisse
faire me semble-t-il ils auraient dû me
semble-t-il aussi rentrer en campagne
beaucoup plus tôt pour s'expliquer
devant les français ça donne
l'impression que monsieur mac route
descend de son piédestal qui les aurait
un chat fait qu'il ait respect quand
même à gérer accession quand on est en
responsabilité c'est vrai que l'on doit
assumer c'est vrai qu'être président
c'est une résidence jusqu'au bout c'est
compliqué c'est toujours compliqué pour
les sortants mais c'est curieux comme on
coupe la parole aussi un débat monsieur
députés sera débat si on peut pas
débattre sahara est en fait un monologue
de alors réaliser notre modérateur qui
va alterner jeu j'y vais je sais je sais
qu'il ya une certaine fébrilité chez
dans l'eau comme monsieur macro mais
bien entendu dans la vienne bien triste
tout à l'heure puisque tout à l'heure à
monsieur maquereau dans sa déclaration
qu'il a faite c'est la première fois
qu'il est vraiment confrontés à des gens
il est descendu de son piédestal il est
allé voir les gens et là il a été quand
même très sérieusement questionné sur la
retraite à 65 ans est quand même c'est
quand même un gros problème quand même
pour beaucoup de ces personnes et
l'une de ces personnes d'ailleurs a fait
état de cela et à l'occasion et un
journaliste d'ailleurs on lui a posé des
questions sur le rapprochement possible
cette ouverture dont vous parliez
effectivement de tout à l'heure et il a
indiqué qu' entre jean luc mélenchon et
lui il avait échangé des sms moi je sais
très mystérieux si vous voulez entre le
président m'a crotoy peu importe mais en
fait c'est assez particulier alors ceci
est seulement je vais vous donner je
vous propose d'écouter justement
emmanuel macron lors de cette visite à
denain dans le nord sur cette thématique
des retraites parce qu'on va se
focaliser un petit peu là dessus dans ce
débat
je suis venu aussi expliqué lena réponse
sociale qu'il ya dans le projet que je
porte en particulier pour les
travailleurs comme pour les retraités
indexés dès cet été les retraites sur
l'inflation c'est-à-dire environ 4%
d'augmentation avoir une pension
minimale pour celles et ceux qui ont
leur courte carrière complète à 1100
euros prendre en compte dans la réforme
que je propose justement la pénibilité
avoir une discussion très large qui
impliquera tout le monde pour en définir
les modalités mais le maquereau qui donc
propose de repousser progressivement
l'âge de la retraite à 65 ans valérie
boyer c'est un marqueur de droite cette
réforme des retraites c'est un marqueur
de la raison mais on verra puisque
emmanuel macron n'a pas commencé à faire
cette cette réforme et c'est vrai que
nous on portait un projet justement de
désendettement de pouvoir à la fois
réconcilier les français les rassembler
bon visiblement nous n'avons pas été
entendus donc c
et si ce qu'un président devrait faire
c'est à dire faire en sorte que le
pouvoir d'achat des français ne soient
pas menacés comme il l'a été sous ce
quinquennat clairement et puis elle ne
pas laisser aussi les français dans la
certitude vous savez quand on à 2800
milliards de dette c'est très compliqué
de réformer donc il faut garder cet
objectif de de passer petit à petit à 65
ans
l'objectif de la réforme des retraites
voulue par m
l'objectif de la retraite faute de la
réforme des retraites voulue par
emmanuel macron c'est avant tout de
faire ce minimum de garanties à 1100
euros est effectivement en prenant en
compte la pénibilité et les carrières
longues et effectivement lorsqu'on est
aux responsabilités et qu'on n'est pas
dans des postures seulement en
promettant ce qu'on pourra jamais tenir
effectivement lorsqu'on les responsables
politiques il faut les financer et ces
mesures elles sont financées comment en
et en repoussant progressivement sur dix
ans l'âge de la retraite jusqu'à 65 ans
tout ça en prenant en compte la
pénibilité les carrières longues et en
garantissant un minimum digne bon vous
savez je dis régulièrement sur les
plateaux télé mais mon père il a
travaillé toute sa vie il est ouvrier et
gagne 900 euros de retraite et je peux
vous dire que ces mesures de minimum
garanti de 1100 euros ça parle aux
classes aux classes modestes et aux
classes moyennes donc je pense que c'est
important et ensuite la question de
l'indexation sur la discrétion sur sur
l'inflation effectivement c'était
indispensable je prends un exemple
uneretraite à 1500 euros c'est 720 euros
de pouvoir d'achat supplémentaire avec
l'indexation et notamment les cadres
vont savoir s'ils vont être mis en place
dès cet été donc ça ce sont des mesures
concrètes débat soutien
l'asie et donne la parole à tous quand
même avoir du mal à vous mettre d'accord
avec une grande partie de l'électorat de
monsieur mélenchon par rapport à cela
puisque monsieur mélenchon lui la
retraite à 65 ans surtout pas justement
j'ai
vraiment que les électeurs de monsieur
mélenchon comprennent que s'ils ont
envie de mettre un bulletin le 24 avril
pour monsieur macron ils auront la
retraite à 65 ans
retraite à 60 ans mais la retraite à 60
ans est fixé à 60 ans et à 62 ans
comment enfin
40 40 annuités si on pense si on
commence à travailler à 17 ans 18 ans 19
ans donc effectivement on pourra partir
à 60 ans la retraite à partir du moment
où il y aura les nuitées nécessaire on
ne change rien on ne change rien à l'âge
de départ légal de 62 6 sites actuels
mais non mes envies s'accentue je
souhaiterais que vous mettez en péril ne
m'en fait le système de répartition de
notre se donnait pas des le sentir quand
on a quand vous avez accrue au cours de
cinq ans la dette publique donc de notre
effectif
total tous ensemble merci monsieur ya
comédie je vais donner la parole à comme
promis à thomas porte sur cette question
des retraites bonsoir thomas porte
est-ce que c'est effectivement
un point j'allais dire saillants du
programme d' emmanuel macron qui peut
vous inciter à je sais pas ne pas aller
voter ou en tout cas aller voter blanc
nous on a donné une consigne de vote est
en tout cas exclu nos positions de façon
très claire hier jean luc mélenchon l'a
répété à plusieurs reprises il n'y aura
pas une voix pour l'extrême droite et on
appelle à ne pas donner une voix à
marine le pen le 24 avril sur la
question de la réforme des retraites on
voit bien que vos deux invités ils sont
1 65 ans l'autre c'était 60 ans a été
abandonné 62 ans et on nous vend la
retraite à 60 ans chez marine le pen car
on commence à travailler à 17 ans alors
qu'on suit bien qu'aujourd'hui on rentre
sur le marché du travail à 23 ou 24 ans
en général c'est ya pas de majorité
politique dans le pays pour emmanuel
macron pour appliquer son projet social
économique il n'y a pas de majorité
politique pour la retraite à 65 ans dans
ce pays elle a été battue en brèche déjà
une première fois qu'un emmanuel macron
a essayé de la mettre en place juste
avant la crise sanitaire où il y avait
des mobilisations sociales
extraordinaire et où les députés da
françaises soumises avait mené un combat
donc personne ne veut de cette retraite
je rappelle quand même que quelques
semaines avant les élections 77% des
français avaient dit qu'ils étaient pour
la retraite à 62 ans voilà on voit
aujourd'hui allez le projet de société
d'emmanuel mc ren quel projet de cité de
marine le pen nous on considère qu'on
combattra marine le pen emmanuel macron
comme on l'a fait depuis cinq ans mais
je le redis ici pour ce soit très clair
pas une voix à l'extrême droite le soir
du 24 avril en première ou oui alors
donc je rebondis tout de suite puisque
l'on vient d'entendre un porte parole de
jean luc mélenchon donc j'ai bien
compris que jean luc mélenchon ne veut
surtout pas qu'une voix à l'extrême
droite bien que je ne sois pas d'extrême
droite enfin passons et surtout donc il
ne veut pas non plus puisque finalement
une faute il va voter niva volts et
blanc donc les autres blancs ils ont
donné comme consigne c'est une consigne
déguisée de voter blanc puisque sur la
retraite ils ne veulent pas de retraite
à 65 ans et ils restent sur la retraite
à 60 ans donc je crois comprendre
finalement que le vote que la consigne
de vote mélenchon c'est en votant blanc
ou s'abstient voilà
non mais je vais réagir parce que
contrairement à votre organisation se
passe le pouvoir en famille nous il ya
quand même une véritable démocratie et
on va consulter celles et ceux qui ont
signé le sur le site jean luc mélenchon
en 2022 dans les prochaines semaines
pour recevoir dans les prochains jours
prochaines sociaux mardi que douze jours
vous faire part de ma profonde tristesse
de voir notre pays avec une sorte de
parti unique
avec effectivement emmanuel macron qui a
réussi son pari un qui devaient se
retrouver dans la même situation
qu'en 2017 c'est à dire pas de débat
comme en 2010 est pas de débat en 2022
et lui face aux partis extrêmes je
rappelle quand même que plus de 70% des
français ne se sont pas prononcés pour
le président de la république même si le
score est important mais surtout pour
gaza mais ce sont surtout des partis
qu'on appelle pas de parti de
gouvernement c'est à dire l'extrême
gauche et est ce qu'on qualifie d'
extrême droite qui l'ont emporté eric
zemmour marine le pen et jean luc
mélenchon moi je viens de marseille et
je peux vous dire que jean luc mélenchon
est arrivé en tête pour la deuxième fois
mais très largement en tête
comme en 2010 est donc on a quand même
un problème démocratique très important
et là effectivement part du pouvoir
d'achat des retraites etc c'est très
important mais il y a aussi une autre
question qui est essentiel c'est quel
est l'avenir de notre démocratie est ce
qu'on veut encore avoir eu un parlement
et notamment une assemblée nationale qui
soit une chambre d'enregistrement de la
macro ni avec des parlementaires
playmobil ou est ce que par exemple la
question qu'on pourrait poser à emmanuel
macron est ce qu il veut toujours
supprimer le sénat qui s'est révélé
comme un contre-pouvoir et qui me semble
absolument indispensable pour le
fonctionnement de la démocratie
aujourd'hui donc on a un vrai un vrai
sujet est effectivement moi je j'ai
combattu depuis ma réélection de députés
et depuis que je suis depuis que je suis
sénateur
emmanuel macron parce que j'ai trouvé
que son quinquennat était celui d'un
populisme mandat et maintenant ils se
retrouvent face et notamment ses phrases
assassines son manque de respect
vis-à-vis des français et aujourd'hui il
est dans une situation ils obligés
d'appeler à l'aide la france un sommet
alors vous ferez quoi parce que gérard
larcher le président du sénat a dit
qu'il voterait emmanuel macron qu'il
mettrait un but un bulletin mâcon dans
lion de bruno retailleau président du
groupe plr au sénat a dit qu'il voterait
blanc est ce que vous ferez vous écoutez
je ne sais pas j'attends de voir quelles
sont les positions des manuels mc ren
encore aujourd'hui parce que il ya
beaucoup de questions qui restent en
suspens un président qui ne veut pas
faire campagne qui rentre en campagne
pendant 12 jours
qui a été extrêmement méprisant et les
français pendant tout son quinquennat
c'est plus de lattre
commencé plus sur l' attitude sur le
court de ramener sur les résultats
excusez moi je suis désolé pas de
réformes un endettement pas de réforme
de l'hôpital pas de réforme des
retraites un déficit du commerce
extérieur abyssal une position sur
l'énergie qui est complètement
incohérente un coup contre le nucléaire
après pour le nucléaire sur le plan de
la politique extérieure je préfère même
pas en parler tellement ça a été une
catastrophe et notamment je pense par
exemple à cette sinistre affaire des
sous marins australiens donc tout ça
pour moi est quelque chose de très
difficile et puis effectivement des
réformes sociétales qui ont encore
diviser les français alors qu'il s'était
engagé à linverse 1
vous voteriez pour lui oui vu la liste
non mais oh
non pas encore je n'ai pas encore pris
ma décision
oui j'ai voté son arme le paiement soit
je n'ai pas encore pris ma décision
toute façon vous savez vous n'êtes pas
non la question ne se pose même pas en
ce qui me concerne étant donné que j'ai
toujours eu pour adversaire le front
national à marseille donc franchement
pas de leçons de morale ou de démocratie
en séance et son initiation on sait ce
que c'est de gagner des élections dans
les villes populaires mais moi je ne
méprise pas les français je comprends
leur désarroi
et je le partage aujourd'hui donc j'ai
dans ce matin j'étais au bureau
politique des républicains effectivement
on a convenu à l'unanimité de se
respecter et de respecter les choix de
chacun moi j'attends de voir ce que le
président de la république va faire va
dire et va promettre parce que jusqu'à
présent à chaque fois qu'on lui a posé
des questions et qu'on a essayé de
travailler avec lui nous avons eu du
mépris et je m'exprime en tant que
parlementaire je me souviens quand
j'étais député nous avons voté 40% des
textes proposés par la majorité ils ont
voté même pas 1% en tant que sénateur
nous avons essayé de travailler et non
pas comme une chambre d'opposition mais
comme une chambre de proposition et
c'est vrai que nous avons été souvent
méprisée dans notre choix et y compris
dans nos dents dans nos propositions
donc moi j'attends que notre démocratie
fonctionne et je suis très inquiète de
voir qu'aujourd'hui on se dirige vers
une sorte de parti unique alors
justement qu'un qui a suscité le rebond
des deux positions sur ce coup mais me
dire se posent en rempart sur cette
question puisque le candidat le candidat
marc andré question a évoqué hier un
grand mouvement politique d'unité et
d'action c'est est-ce dans son discours
dans la soirée électorale six jours d'un
vous pouvez nous nous rejoindre parce
que dans les états majors évidemment
tout le monde a les yeux rivés sur les
législatives
ayman macron a commencé on va dire la
drague et on peut dire ça comme ça danse
de la séduction exactement à draguer à
droite comme à gauche dans la ligne de
mire évidemment les élections
législatives des 12 et 19 juin ça paraît
loin le mois de juin mais ça arrive très
vite et évidemment dans les états-majors
tout le monde un peu la tête à ça ps lr
tous espèrent en tout cas se refaire ou
sauver les meubles peut-être à
l'occasion de ces élections législatives
d'hier une petite phrase des manières
macron n'est pas complètement passée
inaperçue on va l'écouter j'appelle tous
ceux qui depuis 6 ans et jusqu'à ce soir
se sont engagés pour travailler à mes
côtés à transcender leurs différences
pour se rassembler en un grand mouvement
politique d'unité et d'action pour notre
pays et là on s'est tous demandé un
grand mouvement politique d'unité et
d'action qu'est ce que ça veut dire une
question très bonne question en tout cas
beaucoup se sont posé la question
aujourd'hui dans les rangs de la
république en marche qu est-ce qu
emmanuel macron à en-tête précisément
est ce qu'il s'agit de la création d'un
nouveau grand parti unique regroupant
différentes sensibilités un peu façon
ump est ce qu'il ya autre chose en tête
en tout cas beaucoup nous disent
aujourd'hui que le parti la république
en marche et mort le parti la république
en marche et morve une députée la règle
nous disait la chose suivante
aujourd'hui nous n'avons pas su établir
une doctrine est clair la république en
marche n'a pas suffisamment défendu le
clivage entre progressistes et
nationaliste il faut maintenant
reconstruire avec des gens venus
d'autres horizons fin de citation en
résumé comme un petit constat d'échec
quand même après les résultats ce
premier tome et confiance évidemment
dans la possibilité de remporter ces
élections législatives au mois de juin
alors on nous parlait de reconstruire la
galaxie macron pas si simple on en
parlait d'ailleurs la semaine dernière
il ya déjà beaucoup de planètes galaxies
beaucoup de planètes huit formations au
total 1 composent cette galaxie macron
de gauche à droite il ya territoire de
progrès dont le chef de file est olivier
dussopt tu sais que vous connaissez bien
monsieur iacovelli il ya aussi la
nouvelle fédération progressiste de
l'ancien socialiste françois rebsamen ou
encore en commun le parti écologiste
créé autour de barbara pompiers puis au
centre de la galaxie on voit à l'écran
il la république en marche et à
l'historique le modem de françois bayrou
et puis enfin le droit de la macro nice
et le parti radical agirait sa vingtaine
de députés et puis enfin le nouveau
parti d'edouard philippe horizon bref au
total huit formations politiques dans la
majorité mam acronis pour créer un
nouveau grand parti politique unique et
maniema qu'on va devoir ménager tous ces
égos bonne chance merci steve bonne
chance xavier qu il faut encore élargir
ce 8 c'est déjà pas mal huit formations
oui mais en main c'est la capacité
emmanuel macron de d'élargir sa majorité
de 2017 c'était sa capacité aussi
apprendre les bonnes énergies et les
bonnes idées de droite et de gauche moi
j'ai jamais cru à la désire que la
république en art c'est déjà une marque
morte non moi je pense que la république
en marche a été une formidable aventure
en 2017 elle a créé un nouveau souffle
dans la société dont la société avait
besoin avec des paris parti qui était
sclérosé qui n'arrivait plus à se
réinventer et on le voit on le voit
aujourd'hui avec le ps et les verts que
je regrette sincèrement en plus
l'effondrement de de ces partis de
gouvernement mais on voit bien qu'ils
avaient les français avaient besoin
d'autre chose en 2017 donc c'est un peu
trop quand tu viens je viens de cette
famille là je vois pas je me réjouis pas
de lait d'effectivement de l'éclatement
de ces partis politiques vous pouvez le
croire ou ne pas croire mais en tout cas
en l'occurrence en tout cas moi je dans
un département madame boyer qui est
tenue historiquement parler l'air et par
l'ump est effectivement l'éclatement des
dlr provoque aussi des problèmes dans
notre département donc moi je ne me
réjouis pas aujourd'hui que la droite
républicaine
ça fait ça à moins de 5% permettez moi
de le rappeler mais donc je pense que la
volonté d' emmanuel macron et sa
capacité à fédérer les bonnes énergies
de droite et de gauche permet
effectivement d'aller vers un nouveau
projet doivent à nouveau quinquennat
le dépassement continuer à être dans le
dépassement pour l'intérêt général et je
pense que le maquereau nisme c'est du
pragmatisme avant tout et c'est de
répondre aux attentes des français par
des mesures qu'elle soit vous allez vous
allez pouvoir est allé valérie boyer
pour commencer je donne ma parole juste
après oui enfin je suis sensible aux
larmes de crocodile de mon collègue
sénateur mais bien sûr je suis la
provocation mais bon je vois comment
c'est que quand
[Musique]
je vois comment moi je pense que sur la
sincérité et sur la ligne sur la loyauté
j'ai pas de leçons à recevoir
voilà par rapport à ma famille politique
que je n'ai jamais quitté d'autres au
contraire
bien au contraire mais je vois pas le
rapport je pense qu'effectivement les
républicains ne sont solubles ni dans le
maquereau nice ni dans le pénis mme et
que aujourd'hui une des conditions de la
garantie de notre démocratie et d'un
débat et d'un débat pluraliste c'est pas
de se retrouver face face à mélenchon à
quémander des oies de mélenchon
parce que pour moi c'est quelque chose
d'extrêmement dangereux et je crois
qu'il est nous avons chez les
républicains dans cette famille
politique le devoir le devoir de
résister et d'exister pour qu'il y ait
un débat politique dans ce pays voilà on
peut pas avoir une chambre
d'enregistrement avec un parti unique à
l'assemblée nationale et un sénat qui
disparaît si les volontés du président
de la république sont sans réaliser
puisque c'était ça faisait partie de ses
objectifs mais
je crois au débat et je pense que c'est
important d'avoir des partis de
gouvernement et aujourd'hui
effectivement je suis extrêmement triste
pour ce qui arrive aux républicains mais
j'espère que à l'occasion des élections
législatives
eh bien ces candidats de la proximité
ces candidats des territoires pourront
être élu parce que je pense que notre
démocratie on a besoin ce grand
mouvement politique d'unité d'action à
mousser appelée de ses voeux par
emmanuel macron hier soit caisse à
chassepierre j'ai cru que vous allez me
poser la question du grand mouvement qui
est le rassemblement national parce
qu'en fait c'est ça et quand j'entends
quand j'entends mais mes contradicteurs
si vous voulez j'ai le sentiment qu'ils
ne qui n'ont pas encore compris que
quand même il y avait derrière des
français et des françaises qui n'en
pouvaient plus quoi qui n'en peuvent
plus donc maintenant il faut prendre des
décisions est bon je le dis très
simplement et très très amicalement à
valérie boyer on se connaît bien puisque
vous savez j'ai été j'ai été donc à
l'ump j'ai été au haut républicain j'ai
soutenu nicolas sarkozy j'ai des déchets
soutenu françois fillon de très près sur
des sujets notamment de justice je n'ai
pas changé d'un iota mais la donne dans
mes idées depuis 2002 puisque la
première annexion et en 2002 je suis
restée magistrats par ailleurs et je
retrouve naturellement que je suis
aujourd'hui si vous voulez je vous
retrouve à dire finalement les mêmes
choses qu'eux il y a vingt ans ça veut
dire que la france a besoin d'un réel
changement est donc la solution que nous
avons nous bien entendu c'est un
changement qui va enfin arriver
à ce que veulent nos concitoyens
j'entends ce que dit valérie boyer
naturellement mais reportée sur les
législatives encore une fois alors qu'on
sait très bien que le mouvement dlr
c'est terminé que les socialistes c'est
terminé
donc tout ce sont ce sont des mouvements
qui ont il ya une cette recomposition et
je ne crois pas du tout en ce que nous
dit monsieur macron
par rapport évidemment à ce programme
c'est surtout par rapport à ces actions
parce que comment il a mis quand même la
france dans un état en coupe réglée il
ya eu quand même beaucoup de violence
moi je ne veux pas revoir je ne veux pas
en voir les champs elysées où d'autres
villes de france où l'arc du triomphe
saccagés c'est quand même je pars au
revoir c'est gilet jaune je veux qu'on
réponde incombe réponde véritablement à
tout cela je veux qu'on réponde à
l'explosion de la délinquance je veux
qu'on redonne des moyens à la justice à
la sécurité à la police à la gendarmerie
je ne veux pas qu'on fasse à nouveau de
grands débats de grands états généraux
sur la justice les passagers ne va pas
ça sert à rien puisqu'on a déjà déçu on
a déjà des solutions alors nous dire que
demain ce sera la france heureuse et
qu'enfin on a compris au bout de cinq
ans ça ne marche plus et dire que nous
sommes d'extrême droite valérie boyer
sais très bien que je ne suis pas un
extrémiste
j'ai été secrétaire nationale à la
justice de l'ump je n'ai en rien dans
toute ma carrière professionnelle et
politique était un extrémiste et donc
j'encourage valérie boyer eric ciotti et
tous les autres à nous rejoindre et se
fait ainsi à marine le pen depuis ce que
ça change en 2022 est ce que eric ciotti
les marine le pen depuis hier soir je ne
pensais pas je ne pense pas je ne sais
pas mais je ne crois pas non non je n'ai
pas je n'ai pas je n'ai pas
d'information mais ça ne me dérangerait
pas de rencontre et bien sûr eric ciotti
de parler de cela avec lui il faut avoir
du courage je vais redonner la fin je
vais juste après on fait marrer vais te
dire une chose on va porter les 13 et 21
aujourd'hui je nous sommes dans une
situation très compliquée clairement et
très difficile et très douloureuse je
crois qu'il faut pas à minimiser
l'endroit nous trouvons mais moi je suis
j'ai toujours été très proche de bruno
retailleau julien aubert eric ciotti etc
et je partage totalement je ne retirait
pas un mot de ce que nous avons dit dans
le communiqué de presse que nous avons
fait j'ai républicain ce matin et
j'insiste sur le fait pas une voix pour
marine le pen les républicains ne sont
ni fongible dans le maquereau nisme ni
dans le vêtement c'est ce que je vous ai
dit tout à l'heure et moi je comprends
tout à fait la position de
de bruno retailleau par exemple ce que
vous l'avez cité tout à l'heure et nous
sommes ici à public sénat et je la
partage donc un moment donné il faut
être tout en blanc si il faut être clair
aussi dense que nous allons faire mais
j'ai quand même bon espoir que nous
ayons enfin des réponses et une campagne
parce que c'est le moindre respect que
nous devons aux français aujourd'hui
c'est à les adresser à eux et de leur
faire des propositions thomas porte
qu'est ce que vous attendez je suis
toujours sur cet appel à un grand
mouvement d' emmanuel macron hier soir
sur l'écologie par exemple c'est
peut-être là dessus vous attendez des
des gestes là un amendement sur son
programme
nous on n'a rien négocié avec emmanuel
macron et on n'attend aucun geste ou ce
président parce que j'écoutais tout à
l'heure votre présentation et son entrée
en campagne au lendemain du premier tour
où il dit je suis prêt à faire des
amendements à négocier sur l'écologie
mais qui a été aux affaires depuis cinq
ans qui a gouverné ce pays avec une
majorité
quel est le président de la république
qui a été condamné deux fois pour une
action climatique c'est emmanuel macron
dont je crois qu'on a rien à attendre
des manières macro on n'est pas là pour
négocier et le second tour de l'élection
présidentielle
il repose sur les épaules du président
de la république qui s'il veut être élu
doit les convaincre les citoyens il a
passé cinq ans à attiser certaines
tensions dans la société a stigmatisé
une large partie de la population à
faire monter l'extrême droite en
reprenant sa rhétorique en espérant le
second tour et les scénarios
d'aujourd'hui aujourd'hui la
responsabilité elle est sur les épaules
des manuels macron s'il veut gagner
cette élection c'est à lui d'aller
convaincre les électrices et les
électeurs mais en tout cas nous on n'a
rien négocier on attend rien emmanuel
macron
xavier iacovelli va devoir travailler
même macron auprès des électeurs de jean
luc mélenchon c'est je pense que pour le
coup le mot travail est peut-être un peu
fort parce que pour le coup je pense que
ça fait cinq ans qu'il travaille au
service des français mais après sur des
mesures sociales je pense qu'ils
pourraient
apporter
satisfecit aux électeurs de jean luc
mélenchon c'est une mesure par exemple
moi qui mets qui me tient à coeur c'est
la solidarité à la source c'est-à-dire
que pour éviter que c'est le contraire
soit 2
des heures d'activité monsieur pour le
reste vous et nous et ce qu'ils
passeraient bien c'est de lire les
procès une ambiance où viennent de
reprendre les idées de monsieur
mélenchon
a été
de la campagne et en l'occurrence c'est
permettre en fait à tous ceux qui n'ont
pas recours aux aides sociales alors
qu'ils ont droit d'avoir automatiquement
ses l'automaticité des des aides
sociales et donc ça je pense que c'est
important on a à peu près 25% des
français qui ont le droit à des aides
sociales et qui aujourd'hui n'ont pas
accès et donc je pense que c'est
important de cette mesure c'est une
vraie mesure de justice sociale pour
lutter contre la pauvreté et pour lutter
contre le non recours à ces prestations
sociales vous parliez tout à l'heure de
la justice mais effectivement comment
vous pouvez attaquer mais c'est
justement moyens madame non merci
lutter contre la fraude sociale c'est ce
qui se passe d'ailleurs avec le
prélèvement à la source pour les impôts
les impôts des années capitaine vérifier
surnom on le fera également avec les
aides sociales vous parliez prendre la
mesure des vitesses de la justice 33 %
d'augmentation du budget de la justice
depuis le début du quinquennat la
réforme prend 3% monsieur mais oui
vous est ce que vous avez vécu alors
nationaux de travailleurs alors juste
battre j'ai juste mal effectivement les
dégâts le fait du son excusez moi jamais
c'est très très bien je vous remercie de
notation je vous remercie de poser
la réforme pénale des mineurs qui
avaient effectivement ageas que
vous
gardez votre
des mineurs qui font des actes de
délinquance en tant que mineur mais
s'ils sont jugés uniquement en tant que
majeur là on a réduit les délais c'est
ça aussi c'est très fort banc et c'est
aussi entendu vous que faites-vous de la
tribune de 7 mai signée par 7000
magistrats en novembre 2005 et est
reproduit dans le journal le monde
faisant état d'une situation
épouvantable la justice française qui
est à la dernière une des dernières
places la justice européenne qu'est ce
que vous faites de ça on a augmenté le
budget on a mis des personnels donc
c'est bien un magistrat dans les 7000
magistrat je vous signale qu'il y en a
huit mille cinq cents juridictions donc
les quasi totalité des magistrats
français sont des idiots ils sont pas
vus ces 33% en augmentation à du tout je
ne dis pas que c'est idiot moi je suis
conscient qu'il ya énormément de travail
encore à faire pour rattraper les
gouvernements dont vous faisiez partie
nouveau monsieur le député donc
effectivement il demandera tard comme il
y avait sur la question de la sécurité
est de
plus de 10 ce policier et l'horreur
allez je vous laisse pas déroulé sur la
sécurité
s'il vous plaît
[Musique]
si on a entendu vos arguments
j'y serai aux autres je reprends la main
on a évoqué avec vous tout à l'heure
mathieu les forces et faiblesses est les
maquereaux c'est le tour de regarder les
forces et faiblesses de marine le pen
balade pour pour elle son expérience
marine le pen et son sens politique
c'est sa troisième campagne elle a
appris de ses échecs précédents on l'a
senti d'ailleurs dans cette campagne il
a fait preuve de résilience est plutôt
d'instinct pour la première fois le
dispose de réserves de voix ça c'est la
première fois que ça lui arrive ça
n'avait pas été le cas de jean marie le
pen en 2002 n'a pas été le cas de marine
le pen en 2010 est là il ya celle d'eric
zemmour de nicolas dupont-aignan dans
une moindre mesure de certains électeurs
peut-être de léry pécresse et ou de
jean-luc mélenchon qu'est-ce qu'elle a
d'autres elle a déjà remporté deux
batailles dans cette campagne celle de
la proximité je le disais au cours d'une
campagne qui a évité le gigantisme des
meetings contrairement à ses concurrents
dans des grandes métropoles mais plutôt
en privilégiant les déplacements de
terrain des petites villes et puis
l'autre bataille qu'elle a remporté ce
que c'est une des premières à avoir mis
son drapeau sur la thématique du pouvoir
d'achat qui s'est imposé à tous les
candidats mais est la première à l'avoir
senti venir elle a aussi lisse et son
programme un en enlevant toute une série
de totem qui effrayait la plupart
électeurs la sortie de l'euro en
souvenez qui était le plus emblématique
d'entre elles a aussi lisser son image
d'une certaine façon les plus rondes -
moins agressive moins vindicatif que ne
l'était par le passé le front national
de son père et elle a travaillé nous dit
on donc maintenant on attend de voir ce
que ça va donner dans cet entre deux
tours alors que tes faiblesses mais la
faiblesse elle est en seconde position
donc même si elle a des réserves ça va
quand même être dur parce que la
politique ce n'est pas de l'arithmétique
donc quand on regarde déjà ça fait pas
ça fait pas 50% et on va voir ce qu'elle
va donner dans cet entre-deux-tours
deuxièmement elle reste pour beaucoup et
même si
monsieur le député s'en désole une
candidate d'extrême droite soutenus qui
plus est par un autre candidat d'extrême
droite et ça c'est un effet repoussoir
dans une certaine partie de l'électorat
là par exemple des modèles européens qui
sont des modèles autoritaire qui sont
aussi repoussoir pour certains je pense
au président polonais je pense viktor
orban hongrie je pense à ces
déclarations de passer pour la demi
heure poutine tout ça risque de peser
dans cet entre-deux-tours parce que dans
le camp de la majorité on ne va pas s'en
priver autre handicap autre faiblesse
elle n'a jamais rien géré de sa vie n'a
jamais eu de responsabilités pas même
une collectivité locale du coup il ya un
moment les français vont se demander au
fond est ce qu'elle est capable de
prendre en main les destinées de la
france et ce qu'elle a la compétence
suffisante pour le faire autre faiblesse
avec qui gouvernera tu es là à côté de
nous le futur ministre justin garde des
sceaux si jamais marine le pen est élue
puisqu'elle a cité votre votre nom et
pour le reste on voit bien encore avec
qui elle pourra gouverner elle est
parfois un peu mystérieuse parfois elle
donne des noms mais tout ça n'est pas
très complet et puis enfin elle a fait
un très mauvais débat en 2017 qui lui a
beaucoup coûté en terme d'image d'une
certaine façon ça l'a traumatisée on le
sait est ce que ce débat d'entre deux
tours qui est prévue mercredi dans neuf
jours sera pour elle un tremplin ou une
nouvelle déroute c'est là qu'on verra si
elle a travaillé et d'ailleurs vous
proposera évidemment une après midi
spécial autour de ce débat avec sens
public juste avant le débat diffusé en
direct et ensuite une émission en direct
pour analyser ce qui se sera jouée entre
emmanuel macron et marine le pen lors de
ce débat télévisé elle n'a jamais rien
géré de sa vie nous dit matthieu
croissandeau jean paul garraud est ce
que c'est pour vous un handicap un lourd
handicap
non pas du tout parce qu'elle est très
projet français elle a déjà montré les
députés c'est quand même pas un mandat
un qui est très éloigné les français et
puis il regarde il regarde et
déjà sûr mais regardez regardez
justement les collectivités qui sont
gérés par leur rassemblement national et
toutes les mairies toutes les mairies
qui ont été gagnés par le rassemblement
national et/ou dans toutes ces mairies
dans toutes ses structures et bien tous
les maires ont été réélus en améliorant
le score et ça diffuse partout donc ceci
est tout à fait visible donc quand on
compte justement on va vers le
rassemblement national et bien cela
perdure et cela dont ceux s'amplifie
voilà donc après je suis pas tout à fait
d'accord sur un point que vous avez
indiquée par rapport à la pologne et à
la hongrie régimes autoritaires la
hongrie la hongrie vient de réélire
victoire au ban si vous voulez d'une
façon totalement démocratique moi je
voudrais bien quand même qu'on explique
à un moment donné bon parce que je sais
bien que extrême droite mais je voudrais
bien quand même qu'on explique en quoi
si vous voulez la moindre mesure
proposée et d'extrême droite voilà je
n'arrive pas à avoir une réponse pas
rationnel voilà donc je ne sais pas de
préférence nationale peut être la
préférence nationale non c'est ça veut
dire simplement non mais ça veut dire
simplement d'abord qu'on donne la parole
aux français monsieur on donne la parole
aux français par un référendum peut être
que vous devriez changer premièrement
votre
projet c'est moi
l'accès au logement je joue autour de
moi j'ai lu votre programme par mais non
mais alors vous oublié quand même un
élément absolument essentiel c'est que
tout ceci la résultante d'un référendum
avec une proposition de loi référendaire
que nous sommes maintenant que nous
sommes et ont ensuite bien sûr par oui
ou par non à l'approbation des français
et cette proposition de loi référendaire
va amener un certain nombre de
modifications dans la constitution de la
vème république qui si le référendum est
acceptée en traîneront un certain nombre
effectivement d'éléments notamment sur
le fait qu'en france oui bah en france
on va faire en sorte que les français
soient je dirais dans une situation qui
répondent bien entendu au critère de la
nationalité française on accueille
d'accord il n'y a pas de d'ostracisme de
2 ou de rejet mais il ya des choses qui
relève aussi le bon sens je prends un
exemple ne sommes pas des citoyens
par exemple d'un d'un espagnol ou d'un
italien qui travaille en france qui a la
nationalité effectivement italienne ou
espagnole qui cotisent pendant 18 mois
pendant ces travaux mais par contre il
ne peut pas se faire rembourser des
frais des soins de santé puisque votre
projet il y aura la préférence nationale
et donc les désagréments généreront pas
se fait renverser visage d'accord je
vais ainsi à venir magistrat je pense
quelque chose qui vous important pour
vous et notamment la question de
l'égalité devant l'impôt depuis la
déclaration de 1789
vous quand vous parlez de la suppression
de l'impôt sur le revenu pour les moins
de 30 ans ça veut dire que aujourd'hui
je suis un footballeur qui gagne des
millions à l'élever l'intention on a
compris j'ai votre réponse rapide tous
nos bons jeux mais premièrement il
n'aura pas le dernier mot est souvent
s'il vous plaît la mairie vous me posez
cet argument non mais ça c'est facile
donc d'abord il ne vous a pas échappé
que la france était un vaste guichet
social qui a tiré une vaste et
immigration qui ne vient pas pour
travailler mais pour profiter d'un
guichet social
vous savez très bien que c'est pas vrai
a alors là c'est bien ces chapelles tous
les toutes les personnes qui peuvent
regarder cette émission à apprendre
vraiment attiré
jean marie le pen depuis ce je considère
[Musique]
ce débat et le monde terminée
c'est terminé vous pouvez continuer de
débattre mais nous on aura rendu
l'antenne merci à tous d'avoir participé
à ce débat dans 100 publics y en aura
d'autres on va vous proposer des débats
thématiques
dans cette émission et avec évidemment
des représentants des deux finalistes
demain on sera autour de la thématique
des retraites merci à tous encore une
fois d'avoir participé à ce débat il